hello surprise we have a bonus twitch stream i am still epi
so i am still in my epi wear sleepy bird is still here for
the whole today is just sleepy bird day it's my day um but
hello everyone hello hello so i do have a little good news
to talk this not Don't worry, I'm not baiting you guys with
Fortnite.
But Fortnite, Adventure Time is now on Fortnite, guys.
The Ice King is now in Fortnite.
You can make him work, kicks.
Okay, okay, that's not the good news, though.
But Adventure Time is now in Fortnite, guys.
You can be the Ice King.
You can be Lemon Gra.
I'm gonna, actually, I should buy it.
Wait, let me see.
Can I update my store?
Let me update my store real quick, guys.
I knew I forgot to do something.
fortnite anyway um but of course news um for those who are
members um but for those who are non-members a little
reminder um i will be in the tournament for tomorrow um at
12 p.m pst so for the member goons i'll i'll catch up with
you guys right now so basically um they they might have uh
they like So someone was moved to the sub position and I was
I got pulled back into the main roster So yeah, I feel
really bad though, um, but I was supposed apparently I was
supposed to be On the main the main roster for the
participants and then but they like made a mistake and then
I They accidentally put the person who was in a sub roster
in the main roster So they thought they were in the turn and
then they had to move them back to the sub roster and then
me back into the main roster.
So they got swapped, switched up.
I still feel really bad because, like, that person thought
they were in the tournament.
And now I thought I was in the tournament.
And then they're like, no, you are in the tournament.
And I was like, oh, okay, thank you for letting me know.
Okay, thank you.
everything was clarified so tomorrow tomorrow i will be only
in the tournament tomorrow i will be at 12 p.m pst for
marvel rivals and if i sound very tired i am but i still
want to doom queue because i realize there's three hours
left um there's three hours left of rivals ring for this
season and that means three hours left of gatekeeping elo
for people who want to be celestial slash eternity so it's
my time to shine um the elo terrorist is back and i'm on
adult account too i secured my rank that's on you for not
securing yours yeah um yeah i'm gonna be i'm gonna keep some
people for two and a half hours um before uh that's when the
season ends so it's time to be a villain let's go and i
recruited tyanol lover uh to be my co-elo terrorist as well
um oh yeah kyle thank you for the twitch prime thank you
thank you thank you for gifting us up to to eat people thank
you thank you um uh thank you for the raid thank you and
aqua hina thank you for the raid thank you thank you so yeah
um it's it's gaming time but yes thank you to the drag
owners and the members that we trying to figure out because
like for those who are confused during the member stream we
were trying to figure out if I was in a tournament or not
because like um I got the discord invite for the tournament
like like literally like an hour and I think like two and a
half hours ago and then like the tournament was supposed is
tomorrow so um so I was like freaking out because I was just
like what am I am I in I don't know it's tomorrow and then
my apparently like was like um like some apparently like my
invite got lost like my discord invite got lost and there
was like a lot of confusion about it because like they got
mixed up about who's it like about like my participation in
the tournament and they got me swap switched up with someone
else like they like someone else was supposed to be the sub
um but they were accidentally put in the main main
tournament and then i got swapped they like they got me and
this other person mixed up so um they had to like figure
because i told them i told the organizers like i'm confused
because i was counting the official list and i counted like
30 because the player count was 36 and i was counting it not
including me if included me it would have been 37 so i was
so confused and i was like the last i was like one of the
not the last person in the discord but like one of the last
people in the discord because everyone else all the other
like players were there and then like I got really confused
because I was like, wait, my name's not on the list.
And also, if I play, I would be the 37th player.
So then I was like, because the organizers sent me a
discreet invite to the server.
So like, they think they were like, yeah, you're in the
tournament.
And I got in the server and I was like, wait, but where's my
name?
And then I was like, I don't know what's going on.
And then they were like, it got back to me after the match.
member stream so i was so confused and i was like do what do
i do do i show up the
bad at the list do i show up and then and then it was like
oh shit sorry yeah no you're on you're supposed to be
playing like oh we got we got we got this the sub
accidentally got added to the roster but you You were
supposed to, you got, you were supposed to be in there.
And yeah, I was like, am I crashing the party?
I don't understand.
And they, like, swapped me with the other person because
they got mixed up between the two.
I don't know.
I'm just glad everything got figured out because, all I
know, I was going to eloterize because I was really sad
because I was just like, I don't know if I'm in or not.
I told people I was playing.
And are these already public?
No.
I think we'll you guys will find out tomorrow.
Oh, it's drafting.
It's drafting.
It's a live draft So, um, they're gonna be drafting it
tomorrow.
I'll be streaming it on YouTube, by the way.
I'll be I asked if Twitch was mandatory and they're like,
no.
So I was like, oh, YouTube time.
I was like, yeah, YouTube time.
Yeah.
Um, anyway, um, timeline lover, you can queue up now.
You can use VC in matches too.
You want to yell at people.
I think people, I think people will know who you are the
moment you use VC, but that's fine.
But you want to yell at people.
It's, it's, it's, it's, okay.
Okay.
Thank you.
It's, it's, it's, it's Gomez.
Um, because I did say I owe him a game.
Like I owe him some games because I, I did pick Moxie over
him.
So I was just like, you down to play?
you you're down to play I'm here to ruin people's time it
was whether or not it was like if I was in the tournament or
not I was gonna I was still gonna Elo terrorize it doesn't
really matter so um so I was just like I was just gonna it
was gonna do what I do yeah no I did not give him the pass
to use the other account
um Can I explain myself or no?
He has like stream delay.
So he'll hear that in 10 seconds.
There you go.
It's like...
Here you go.
Mid, thank you for the 100 bitties.
Thank you, thank you.
I was like, just give it a second.
It'll respond in 10 seconds.
There is stream delay.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
I might be lagging, but I can fix it.
It's because I was doing...
It's because I'm not full of screen, so I'll do that now.
Oh my god, we have three streams.
I have to Elo-Terrorize.
But yeah, thank you all the drag who was during the member
stream.
For like keeping me calm.
Because I was panicking.
I was freaking out.
Because I was like, am I in?
I was like, I thought, I thought I was in the, it was, it
was so awkward, because it was so awkward.
It was like, here's the invite, and then I joined the
server, and then, like, I joined the server, and then I, I
didn't see my name.
And it was, like, a full lobby.
So I was just like, oh, oh.
I was like, what do I do?
Yeah, public humiliation ritual.
Yeah, they invited me just to be like, you're not in.
I thought I was just like, what?
Just like, quietly in the background.
Just to be like, yes, who's not in actually?
That was me crying.
This is my, this is how I cry.
Wait, it's just sexy.
Guys, this is my crying sexy.
Very sexy.
This is how I cry.
I could put a low key.
I see as I run out as Rocket.
Wait, how can you do it again?
It's not ugly.
It's that key.
People, I thought...
Wait, what is this?
Oh, yeah.
People say, when anime women cry, it's high.
Is this not hot?
Ehh!
She lied to me!
What the fuck?
I don't come down everyone, calm down, know it was very
sexy.
Don't cry my little baby.
Please stop.
I just...
I just wanna be skinky.
Can I get a bubble?
I'm gonna see you.
Okay, there we go.
Oh shit.
Don't cry, my kid.
Okay, I should stop this.
Oh wait, they're running rockets, too.
What the fuck was our Thor there, though?
I don't think I'm in time.
I don't understand it's how I cry I thought it's a cry
reveal are you not do not like my cry review I'm revealing
my cry oh goodbye Ty and I love it oh bro I'm fucking high
in here Wow That...
That is unfortunate.
Um, I'm almost there though.
You're sick, so it's different.
There's a banger of the name.
That's why I say I love Bravo's names.
Let's cry.
I have not stopped right-clicking since I started crying.
There's no way you're asking me to a right-click harder.
Like, I literally have just been spitting balls out.
There's no way.
I can't spit it out harder.
It's, like, literally just ingrained.
I don't think we're winning this, but it's okay.
That means my team is losing, Elo.
It's not just me.
My entire team is responsible for today.
Look, I really want to up, but you guys gotta push up,
though.
Like, I don't know how I'm going to up this if none of you
push up.
Fuck this, here you go.
Okay, like, there's nothing I could do about that.
Nice.
As there's, I am doing everything I can.
Oh, you see this?
You see how I'm right-clicking so fucking hard right now?
Like, the only time I have not right-clicked is when I have
to reload my gun.
Risa and Fajra, thank you for the raid.
Thank you.
We had a great stream.
I did feel bad, though, that the other girl
was moved over.
Because, you know, someone, there's like winners and losers.
It's okay.
If one of us dies,
Yeah, I felt bad about that.
Oh, hey.
You first, yeah.
I tolerate raccoons.
But now, now I hate...
I hate mutants more.
Alright.
Oh, nice.
Oh, not nice for this guy.
I've always hated what do you mean what you I've always
hated mutants more it has not changed oh that is not good
that is that is not good well my all this self my ult is
gone all right it's fine
I've I've not stopped healing I'm sorry man Like, you cannot
blame me on that.
I've been spitting them out.
We unfortunately do not have a Naruto anymore.
I hear you.
I've been clear regarding what I hate since the beginning of
season zero.
This is Magneto's America.
And I've had enough!
I've had enough!
I speak for the humans!
Yeah, mutants have always been my number one.
There we go.
Whoa!
That's right, again!
And again!
Don't worry, as a almost human representative, I will speak
for all of you.
I'm like at least 10% human.
But I think I am at least 10% human, so I am just to fight
to speak for all of you you're not a human you're Canadian
you know bananas have like was it 10% human DNA I'm friends
with a lot of humans yeah I think it was like how many
percent was it I don't think it's 10% but I know it has an X
amount of percentage of human DNA.
So that doesn't mean banana...
That doesn't...
Oh yeah, 50%.
Sorry, that was me underselling it, apparently.
Bananas have almost 50% human DNA.
So that means that, guys, that doesn't rule out tomatoes.
I don't know, someone saw a banana and was like, that's a
sexy banana.
our cousins with bananas the banana started crying and then
the human was like dots he's like
fuck the banana do not the banana
Okay, I think it's human nature when like, you're like, can
I, can I bang that?
That's human nature.
Uh, yeah, but with holes, sorry, not with that.
Yeah, with holes.
They're like, can I stick the PP in there?
That's like, bananas are more human than mutants.
And that's why bananas have more rights.
Oh, that guy is dead, dude.
Don't worry, Thor.
Don't worry.
Take this.
That's why we love bananas more than we love mutants.
Oh, good for the Thor.
Alright.
Nice.
Oh, shit.
That guy got fucked up It's a penny still a lot the penny is
still a lot only because the wings the web stuff is still
here Thank you
You don't know that You don't know if there might be human
DNA and tomatoes You don't know that Oh shit, that's the
moon is here The moon is looking nice tonight Don't worry, I
have res.
Die on point!
Die on point, I have res.
Okay.
I no longer have res.
How do we even fact check that?
You can't trust the internet no more.
You can only trust Doki News.
The internet is written by a mutant apologist.
The only source of information you can trust is Doki News.
Yeah, that's right.
Yeah, exactly.
And Doki News says that tomatoes have human DNA.
Yeah, AI is mutant based.
Exactly.
Don't worry.
I will be the noose that you can trust.
I will be there for the people, for the humans.
Oh, nice.
Cool.
Yeah!
Rocket!
For the people, for the humans!
Just like in Greendale, we are for the humans.
Gotta get my water.
Yay!
My team was just ignoring you didn't have much of a choice.
I have Thor.
I mean, I don't think our Thor was the...
the threat here.
Our Thor with the four final hits?
It's okay.
Of course.
Of course a gooning dragon says that.
It's okay.
You know, the only sad part about being in an alt account is
that we don't have our favorite our favorite emote.
Ew, we have a fucking mutant on my screen.
Get that shit out of here.
It's alright.
Even though you can't dance for me.
Wait, how do I...
I don't remember how I put you on my screen.
It's been too long.
Oh, there we go.
Alright.
No!
I have a stupid mutant on my screen.
Okay.
cake is cake yeah but wolverine's cake is flat as fuck he
should be ashamed of himself
oh shit tabbed out i'm scared of tabbing out in this game
now because like when i i tabbed out like i did like an
off-stream game just to like warm up also i i did need it to
um oh wait what is this oh my god it's dancing most with ice
king oh my god guys important update look at this anyway i
did an off-stream game to warm up and i had to play it
anyway because you know tournaments tomorrow yeah warm up
warm up they did have one because they banned the character
um wait what was i talking about i already forgot before the
important update part
sorry i got i lost my train of thought
oh yeah i played a game i had to play i played a game off
stream um off stream to to just like warm up a little bit
and then um and then I tabbed out, like it was the first
game, I tabbed out and then my entire PC crashed.
So now I'm paranoid as fuck now about tabbing in and out.
Why is Ice King dressed up?
Because in one episode, he became his natural pure element.
He's like fit as fuck.
He's not actually, that's just his beard, but during his
most, pure this pure element and he's going on a date he's
gotta look hot he's gotta know that look nice for his
princess i don't unfortunately on this account we do not
have we do not have our gooner skin unfortunately oh my gosh
i've added my i should have added my main account and
started gifting my alt account gooner skins.
I just don't plan my ults to justify this.
The only reason why this ul was even oh I am sorry.
The only reason why this ults is even this elo is because my
manager wanted people to play, wanted someone to play rivals
with and then I ranked it up for him.
I was like, okay.
Oh.
Oh, that's embarrassing.
Alright.
But yeah, I said like, I'll help you.
I'll help you rank up.
For like this season.
And I was like, that is the only reason why I have a high.
Like, not high, you know, it's GM.
That's also the only reason why I have a GM account, I'll
check out.
Because I said, okay, I shall help you this season.
Because he's like, he complained to me about how he's in Elo
hell.
He's in Elo hell and he's solo cute.
I felt bad and I was like, okay, this season I play.
Oh, I don't like that.
What is that?
Oh, oh, no.
Oh, no.
We don't need it, right?
That's unfortunate that we don't need it.
I could have saved this.
It's alright.
Come back.
Or a zoo.
I already copied.
I didn't think we won.
See, look, we got kills.
It was worth it.
We got kills.
We got staggers.
You cannot say that wasn't worth it when we got staggers.
Look at that.
We got two, three, we got another stagger.
All because I ulted it there.
Oh, the coward.
So you're welcome.
All me.
Literally all me.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, more.
Whoa, whoa.
Is that fucking more staggers?
Holy shit.
Let's go.
More fucking staggers.
Oh, never mind.
Our guy got staggered now.
Oh, he got my clone.
Fucking idiot He's stupid
Oh, there you go just in case That is Look at that.
Oh, look at that all me all me Oh, because of my aura all
that we had and never-ending stagger you're welcome team
you're well i started the cycle i started this oh that is
embarrassing oh dokey okay dokey is scared now dokey was one
hp dokey was scared she was one hp
come here come here come here we fight here we fight here oh
my god we fight here oh okay oh i did not realize like i
don't know that's fine that might not have been very aura
i thought we would all push forward sorry that was my bad
hello that's That was my bad.
That was not aura.
That was my bad.
It's okay.
It doesn't matter.
We still win this.
Look at that aura.
We only win this because of my aura.
It's still worked out.
It does.
I made a mistake and we still win.
So in the end, is it really a mistake?
It can't be a mistake if we're winning.
If you think about it.
That is not good.
There we go.
Who the fuck did I kill?
Oh shit.
Guys, guys, you cannot.
Guys, guys, no!
Oh wait, it's fine.
Look at that.
Bated.
Oras, ora.
A part of the process.
Look at that.
i baited him i baited him with my clones in me calculated
dies from aura no way never punished let's go
yeah look at that
Look at that, guys.
Yes, and I trust you, the damage that I'm willing to...
Never punished.
I'm going to be cosplaying Anna Overwatch.
Oh, you're going to be doing Anna?
Okay.
That should I order for you?
No one ever asked, are you actually Doki Bird?
But you're one of the best spies in the world, Natasha.
Yeah, see ya, I am the homie.
Whoa!
I got touched already.
I don't like that.
Oh my god, they're trying Storm again?
I mean, okay.
Oh, okay.
Sorry, I did not have...
I did not realize he was gonna fucking die.
I did not realize they were both gonna die that fast.
It's okay, guys.
It's not okay.
Our stranger might be dead, but...
Okay, it's okay.
I have two of me.
Two of me can bring us back.
Okay, there is...
It's okay.
He messed up.
Oh, my...
My God.
Jesus Christ.
That is a lot of damage, I will say.
I am trying so hard to heal everybody right now.
Alright, I'm building my nano booster.
Okay.
It's okay, right?
Everything is okay, right?
Oh, he has one!
Oh!
He was one.
He still is one!
Oh my God.
You're flying.
It's so hard to hit.
So good luck.
Wait, this sucks.
Wait, it fucking sucks.
Well, that got fucking shit.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
Oh my god, it's okay.
Ha ha ha Look at that I am the Loki player.
I'm Loki doki.
Loki bird What the fuck he's still alive?
I need to do the press to confirm shit by the way There is
someone behind me I was like I feel like I hear But I'm
gonna kill him anyway Nevermind
I'm gonna even grab this just in case.
That's fine.
He missed too.
It's so fine.
There are so many things on my screen.
But I think we're okay.
Holy shit.
Alright.
There has...
Oh my...
Okay, that is awkward.
I thought we were like...
Oh no.
It's right here.
He's coming closer.
He's coming closer for people.
Oh, he's got a lot of them.
Look, I use my Involve so like good luck everyone.
Alright, it's fine.
We are good luck.
Okay, it's fine, it's fine.
We're okay.
I had to use that.
I got scared.
I like inked.
Every time I use Involve, it's me inking.
I was like, oh no, they're getting closer to me.
Okay.
Oh, my.
Oh, please.
That is unlucky.
Ah, strange dot.
Oh, yeah.
I got passed by.
I know.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, I played my KD.
Wait, was she holding?
I don't know if she held it.
or she had her she literally just got her ult maybe it could
it's happened before because I didn't see if she had her ult
before oh it's okay that's okay we're in the ult no see it's
okay and then we kill her look at that gaming look see we
game it's okay it's okay there's no way he's gonna again
this right
We'll be fine, right?
I'm just...
Yeah, we can kill it from here, right?
Yeah, I'll just say it.
That's fine.
I did not have to...
You know what?
I think we're fine.
Okay, so I have another aura right here.
There we go.
That's fine.
It's just It's fine Oh my god Another one Oh shit Okay
that's awkward There we go We should be fine I think that
wasn't even aura I think that was just a good alt overall
That was a decent alt overall I think It's not even aura If
it's just a good alt like we live we didn't die so
technically because everyone is alive it's a good all i mean
everyone but super gomez like that's just one person i just
realized their only tank is an angela that i got dumped
that's pretty stupid oh that's bad that's bad very bad it's
okay i did not the good thing is that that is not good that
is not good i didn't by the way i where's my oh she died
it's okay we have invisible she can save her she did not
save you can save yourself please no why why didn't you
answer you could have saved yourself
oh my god where is she oh my god they see nine oh my gosh
she didn't get punished okay but that's an
avoid right there.
Oh, yeah.
We take those, but I also have to avoid this person.
At first, you know, I gave her the benefit of doubt.
I was like, you know what?
She might have got the odd, but I literally saw her hold it.
She held it for that game, and she was so lucky we had TP.
She almost sold there.
Yeah, but it's okay.
It's okay.
Wait, apparently I can afford the venom?
Cannot?
Oh, 500.
Wait, wait, battle pass.
I must have enough.
I might have the free currency.
Oh.
Lists.
Wait, I have enough now.
Yeah, she kept holding it.
I don't know.
She was playing chicken with it.
Okay, someone said it 600 and now i have 700 so oh
my god life is good life is good there we go get this muting
off my screen good timing because i actually have to pee
yeah Bum-Bum.
Whoa!
Two more hours of Yelot terrorism.
I gotta pee.
I'll be right back.
I've been hydrating a lot because I've been coughing a lot.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
Who am I gonna banish from this match?
I am back.
Made it.
Don't worry.
I am a pro...
beer i'm streaming for so long i have it down to a system
now
i can't wait to be to be better i can't wait i'm going i'm
actually going to go to doctors on saturday so i'm hoping i
can uh hoping i can you know recover in time
Like, I just, I don't want to, I'm worried if I wait too
long.
If I wait too long, it won't be good.
Doctors open on the weekends.
Well, let's find out and see.
I'll find out.
I'll look it up tomorrow.
Because I have to call as well.
About it.
I'll call tomorrow.
Alright, who do we ban?
I had to check something real quick
What am I playing?
Oh rocky raccoon.
Let's go I'm not I'm so I'm only solo healing on rocket You
think they I care Bro Give me give me your rocket.
I want it No
Yeah, but I could DPS it.
There's no shooter like me, buddy.
Nah.
Gift me subs.
I did and you'd even play with me yesterday.
I'm playing.
I'm playing with you now.
That's where I hold this.
I'll even hold my duo hostage.
I'll hold.
I'll hold even my duo hostage.
No one is safe.
Shameless.
I wanna rock it.
Me rock it.
Are we gonna really okay?
Oh fuck!
Okay, it's okay.
I'm okay.
I'm in my own little cubby hole.
Nothing to worry about.
Watch this.
I have ult soon.
See look.
It's got my hook though.
Are you gonna love this one?
Oh, she's streaming late.
Joke's on you.
This is my third stream.
Oh, shit.
You know, they'll be fine, right?
Yeah, they'll be fine.
That was a good ass up.
Yeah.
It's not because I'm streaming late.
That's because it's never stopped.
I say as I hack my lungs out.
Yeah.
See, nothing to worry about.
See, if we went double support.
Okay, that was my bad.
That was...
That might have been my bad, guys.
Alright, guys, you might not have a support, but it's okay.
You don't need a support.
It's okay.
You res.
See?
I just 1v4?
What the fuck is?
Please 1v5.
You can 1v5.
Don't let your dreams be dreams.
Oh my god.
There we go.
See?
You can 1v5.
Don't let your dreams be dreams.
1v5.
Alright.
It's fine.
What?
Oh, it's like an illegal...
It's an illegal...
can't be legal here oh poor guy all right here we go this is
where i uh watch this right here
watch it right here jesus christ it's okay i guess we we did
not need that i guess we don't need my oh i guess oh my god
what the fuck is going okay let's just use it oh it's five.
They technically use three alts if you think about it, so
it's a good value.
Alright, there you go.
I live though.
So like, I don't know.
The carry's alive.
Oh, I can build it again because like I can build this up
really oh, that's unfortunate.
Oh, that's that is also unfortunate.
um oh that is also very unfortunate it's okay it's okay it's
okay i got all charged
oh look look we have luna
it's fine oh we have invents it's even better all right look
at that see that's all you have to go do that's all we have
to do wait until someone's ego look see look at that oh all
right guys i think we can chill guys i think we can wait
guys i don't we don't have to run oh oh okay okay thor oh
you know i should expect it in this you though that makes
more sense i could play loki and make this easier for all of
us
That's, you know, that's, okay.
That's, well, unfortunate.
But, it comes out in two hours.
I mean, I can all this.
Bro, you gotta stop taking damage, bro.
If you wanna know why you're stuck in this Elo, you are, you
gotta stop doing what you're doing right now.
Like, if you are wondering why it has not been working, and
you are still here this is why oh yeah like if you're like
oh i can't believe i'm not okay and also that too our we
just use it this was already winnable that i okay guys guys
i okay it's fine moon night it's okay we're all little
special well
not everyone at least like uh our mag like everyone else
held their odds but oh wait never mind it's because everyone
did not have their odds that's why they held it that makes
more sense oh okay oh man if only we had a mag oh that'd be
pretty neat oh my god are you serious all right let's just
get it let's get it let's get it I have many faces.
Big meat!
Oh, I fucking actually pressed shift.
That is not good.
I did not mean a pressed shift, but that's okay.
Oh, wait, C9.
Let's go.
Let's fucking go.
Let's fucking go!
I love myself, C9.
It's okay.
There's a reason why both teams are in this Elo.
But Doki, you're in this Elo.
It's by choice.
It's not by choice for the others.
Okay, okay, look.
Our Invis did not turn to my right.
Turning up the heat.
And here we go again.
Actually, I don't know if I should definitely swap off Loki.
I didn't realize they had, I forgot they had Moon Knight.
I have I don't have double confirmed so like I'm like scared
for myself
Bro, oh my god.
She got the wrong fucking invis.
That's fine by me
That's fine.
They actually he actually got the wrong invis
What the fuck hello?
I did not even see that guy what let me up please I'm the
size requirement okay I hope hey guys oh that's fine they
like split us for the red thank you thank you uh rinsky
thank you for the five gifted subs thank you thank you
you'll need a top-notch team to win this one thank you thank
you for the go after shows i really appreciate it i
appreciate you too all right i can't be low-key because
they're i'll be rocking just because like they're running
moon night and he can farm that off he can farm the odds off
of me And we don't fuck where's at.
That's bad.
That's bad farming.
It's back on rocket duty.
As I did rock Luna, but I think rocket is better.
I'm trying not to I'm trying my best not to to eat too many.
I know that yo, you have cough drops.
I already had four today.
Okay.
so i'm trying not to um over yeah overdose but it's also not
good not good to have too many cough drops per day so i
already have four today yeah or it's not like um what's the
recommended amount i don't remember but i know four because
i threw away the boxes but i know four is already a lot
because it's also that because it's also not good for your
teeth so i'm not i'm trying not to like do too much because
it's they're like they're like sweet too so they're not like
good for your teeth in general if you have too much oh
that's unfortunate oh that's also unfortunate um so we're
solo healing but it's okay it's like how we were doing
earlier i'm not seeing oh hey guys you Whoa.
Goodbye.
Who will win?
Our Moon Knight or their Moon Knight?
Yeah, no, that was definitely like anti-brut.
Oh, Luna.
No, I guess I play.
No, I'm gonna say Rocket for the team.
I feel like I have to.
Jesus.
What?
How?
Where was it?
it is it the Luna oh my god the Luna the oh my god because
the Luna was next to me that is so unfortunate the way stay
alive I'm sorry they hit a checkpoint now might be a good
time to stop them yeah I don't go I'm saying Rocket only for
the Until we're on Ultra only because Our Star Lord has a
team up Like it's worth it I will say I can tell that this
other person Does not play support For sure I also will say
That we might not win this Because I don't Believe in my
team I'm sorry.
I know I should believe, but it's very hard to believe in
this team
I'm just gonna press kill Where was he?
No
I was I dropped down and I was gonna press kill I'm so sad
I'm so sad Okay, we got it It's gonna go down right away.
Okay.
I guess that was the best I could do for it.
I'm sorry I tried to live Okay, now I swap Now I swap.
I'm sorry.
You're not getting that team up.
I have to swap to Invis It's all right.
We I mean like we made it five bro that guy is like Good
luck.
You got no team up now I just think that's fine like this
team is just um i will say our tanks um like i know the name
says tanks but like like guys guys you gotta it's 19 and 15
oh i'll fight for my family until the end i no i actually
under but like they just think the tanking part is like oh
my no i told you me it's a choice this is not a choice for
them and somehow i have the least amount of deaths
Bro, even the enemy team was like, bro, forcing, forcing
Thor.
Even the enemy team, but he was like, bro, stop.
Yeah, boy.
I hear you.
He has 10k damage?
Hey, Paco.
Yeah, I have some.
I have some.
Yeah, even the enemy team knew he was a problem.
Yeah, what was he...
Bro, okay, he has 20 deaths, though.
That guy was not playing.
Like, he was playing.
You know what?
And now it's this time!
Alright, let's bet if he's...
If he's hidden profile or not.
Oh, I avoided him.
I have to do it here.
Yeah, bro, he broke my road!
He broke my yellow brick road.
Let's fuck it Oh my god, you have no shame wait, he said
eternity
How oh my god all he did was just farm zombies wait
That's crazy That is crazy wait, that's literally all he
plays Does he play anything else?
how is he even Thor oh that's why he hasn't touched this
game oh my god he literally came back he came he hasn't
played this game in like one two three four five six oh my
god six seven how is that six I'm sorry, I'm fucking pretty
right.
I said it.
I took the power from you guys.
I know you guys were going to say it.
So I took the power from you guys.
I'm reclaiming it.
He hasn't played in six seasons.
And that's why he has a fucking 30.
He has that have a win rate.
Because he's just been farming low Elo.
And then coming back here.
Yeah, bro came back just for zombies.
That's like insane.
Literally, that's all he's been doing.
He's just been farming low elo.
We don't even get them.
What the fuck is the point?
What's the point of avoiding?
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
Oh, we got one of the Moon Knight one tricks.
I wish I could play in borderless window mode so I can just
tab in and out.
an adam one trick oh my gosh this yellow is fun as in fun as
special i'm seeing fucking characters that i've never seen
before no i'll do it no why would you ban phoenix out of all
why would you ban her over hella shot him up it's not fair
okay so why not double pennies are also really good hella
and namor is really it's not fair it's not fair she's not
fair i've been out there so long
the devil we can somewhat deal with because if we go triple
support i don't play fucking luna in 20 years since he's a
six star not since he's a six i haven't even started since
season five started guys Or four?
I've been in like Invis, Loki, Rocket, and Gambit.
I'm tired of Luna.
I ain't, I'm not playing with you no more.
That's for bitches.
Why?
Why I could do Mantis.
I don't know.
You are GM low peak.
Shut up.
GM low peak.
Bitch, we're in the same ship.
He's a brain.
What you want Scooby snack No, I want a carrot I want a
carrot Alright Alright We're the same, does he know?
Does he know?
Damn bro, you gotta go out in the sun and get some light
Alright, let's go Ashmanicus tag There is nothing to fear.
Here we go.
I'm basically a black bar right.
I haven't played Mantis in a long ass time, so let's see.
Let's see how how handicapped I am right now.
Oh my god, it's Moon Knight versus Moon Knight fucking.
Since I got triple support, I'm going to keep...
I mean, have triple support jesus christ
because i do not have my sticks
what the fuck okay if he has it that means our guy yeah i
was gonna say that means he has it too
yeah why is it always okay oh
what people are doing in this map.
It's boring.
No, it's not.
I never seen them.
That's where they go, and we need more damage output.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, this guy is stupid because it's this map, but
that's no.
He has not been outside of GM.
You can tell.
Because I do never see Hawkeye Moon Knight unless, like,
it's Moxie, and he's the Hawkeye Master.
Like, I'm like, bro, that is not because of this map.
That is not what this people play on this map.
Nice, nice, nice.
I'm going to rush the back line.
I got close.
Focus pin as well.
Boy, I can't roll.
I'm kind of sick.
Oh, she got res, guys.
Oh.
I'm harassing them over here.
Stopping them from moving.
But I need someone to help me secure them, though.
I can't.
I don't have the DPS as much.
We kill two.
Guys, okay, I need you guys.
I'm gonna see you guys.
Okay.
Alright.
This Eno is very interesting.
I'll say it.
This is a very, very interesting Eno.
I shouldn't even out there, bro.
I should have like put two and two together to punish these
young.
That was just like, I heard him out.
But then I realized both the healers are on me.
Bro, oh my god, he's having a life story right now.
He's trying to like and analyze everything.
It's crazy.
Get free on cart.
Let's get free on cart.
We're overextending right now.
Bro, what?
We don't gotta.
Our, our, our Luna overextended for sure.
I would say that.
But that one of the hills will be my program.
I've only got Matthews going right now.
I got no ragged.
Okay, bruh.
On my screen, it did the slam.
Are you serious?
Yeah.
Okay.
Let me see this.
Oh, good.
oh my god it traveled i was not even in the circle it
traveled 80 miles away
bro i need you to peek me if you want any heals all right
that's fine i'm trying not to get get on right now i'm just
really i don't there's no dps like flyer that's a hit scam
i'm having a little story here thank you just play old chon
bro oh my god yeah he's fucking dead three in car bro the
card is auto pushing bro three in sky okay yo friend card
friend card friend card friend card Bro, no, you're stupid.
You're fucking stupid.
Bro, it's all about getting the staggers.
Oh, no.
This guy is stupid, though.
Yeah, now look at that.
Now that guy was almost going to die because of you.
Hey, you got a sand cart.
I'm going to push up for him so we can make a pass there.
Fuck this.
Let's go.
Oh, there you go.
See, look at that.
I started the fight.
I'm not going to.
Look at that.
I started the fight.
You're welcome I engage Let's just back up his back up his
good point Oh my god Nice clutch, yeah, clutch his mag He's
capped, he capped, he capped Alright, there we go I swear,
all I'm doing is just I'm just healing right now There's,
we're always, I always have to heal Can we like shoot this?
I'm blocking the Hawkeye out?
Shit on Hawkeye all right there you go i just i i can't do
anything i have to use this all on heels we're all i only
went mantis because like we were on triple support so this
is a lot harder uh focus right here yeah we just run right
here nice yeah that's dj the current score is good round
good round good round
He's so confident, dude.
That's the crazy part.
He's so fucking confident.
All right, so.
Did they play Mag?
I think we need a score, girl.
He did not play Mag, right?
It's close to have.
No, Moxie's in eternity.
I thought I'm in eternity.
Bro, what the fuck is he saying?
Yeah.
There's no way that guy heard what he said.
Wait, did they play mag?
They were.
I swear to God, I saw, I felt like I saw zero mag.
Okay, I did not.
God damn it, I'll never be able to play this game.
I am not playing.
I'm not playing mag.
I literally have to spam heals all day.
I need to elaborate.
Then you're in this corner right here.
Like this one?
Yeah, like the first corner.
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
Do I still have time to reach one above all?
you had two hours i actually don't know what console yeah
honestly i will tell you i have no idea what console one
above all rank is but you are there you have no you have no
chance in pc i would say that two hours is like not a lot
the volume is up it is not up oh it is up it's it's usually
maxed up i'm pretty sure i mean you guys could hear everyone
else right Okay, versus him.
It's all right.
I am.
Don't worry, guys.
I'm right-clicking.
Yeah, it's literally the Earth, guys.
Like, bro, we cannot hear you.
I'm not going to make sense.
The Bucky's back.
He's going to try to block me.
Oh, no ways.
Got to block.
Unfortunate.
I don't know why he's on Storm.
I'm going to keep trying to, like, block the hot guy shots
with my body.
Oh, my God.
It's okay, it's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
That got one and he dead, but it's okay.
Oh my god, that double moon knight.
The double moon knight.
Nice, nice.
That's wild.
How are I getting the moon?
My moon knight was stronger.
Snipe.
I had the stronger moon knight.
That's fucking right.
Put it here.
Oh, he died before my thing.
I said, unfortunate and then jump so he doesn't headshot me
and just block shot so if i drop them oh nice oh my moon
night stronger get diffed i mean well she might not on them
oh that's been working there you know what i'm talking about
oh my god my moon night diffs your moon night oh got back up
it's fine we'll be fine oh thank god okay i was so tempted
to that but let's So she doesn't get headshot, guys.
Yeah, we're getting head-tapped.
Yay!
The boss supporter!
No!
Okay, I guess.
Okay, that might have been too many else.
Maybe.
Sometimes imagine, like, my squirrels having rabies and,
like, like, chewing them to death.
Probably see you.
Yeah.
from your squirrels with you're ready for okay literally i
think he's high i think our mag is a little high for sure oh
holy it's okay it's like i believe in our our moon night
it's okay if all else fails we have our moon night that's
okay our luna is like a little bit i our luna is a little
our luna is a hundred percent scaring me right now our luna
our luna i've okay luna okay luna you oh my god oh my god he
doesn't know he doesn't know he does he's so bad he's
actually he's actually so bad holy i lived i got worried on
myself okay
I'm back.
Okay.
I'm immediately fucking this hawk at the moment I spawn.
Fuck you, bitch.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
Up here.
No way.
I'm so bad.
These people.
Give me a solid hug.
I told you.
Me being in the silo is a choice.
That's just a lot of good.
I'm not going to do.
No!
Oh, you never missed that.
I'm just gonna occasionally pick this up.
I got his own install!
Both the Luna and the fucking squirrel girl.
I got you with that though.
Maybe I do.
This deal has a choice.
I am ready to put on a show.
I told you.
Just use cards covered.
I'm gonna keep trying to block the Hawkeye shots.
I told you guys.
I... This is very...
This is special.
Only...
I know only in this.
Okay, I need an ult here.
There we go.
I better see this ult.
I'm not gonna ult, bro.
They already like this.
oh i just killed everything that was crazy i that was that
was embarrassing i'm sorry like at least three people in
this on the enemy team has to like it's not the game is at
this point it's it's you it's not the game i'm sorry like
they're like i don't know why i can't get out are you
serious I can't get out of GM.
There's a reason.
And I saw that reason.
Yeah.
That's okay.
My moon night comes back.
I've got no bubble for you, sir.
You got you dead.
That's okay.
He's fine.
Don't keep there already dead.
I'm on the plane.
Mommy's just cute.
All right, here we go.
That's crazy.
The fact that I took someone down with me.
Oh, random pot shot.
I don't think he's done on you.
Yeah, I knew it.
I'm fucking backing out, bro.
That hot guy is not taking me down.
If Moxie didn't take me down during that preview, none of
these guys are taking me.
That's fucking right.
There we go.
I'm gonna knock off all.
Alright, nice.
Bro, I'm not letting a GM Hawkeye take me down.
Bro.
I managed to dodge all of Moxie's headshots during the
preview stream.
Like, Siphon tanked all of the fucking headshots and I
dodged all of them.
I'm not letting some G GM Hawk, I take me down.
Yeah.
GG, time to be in Celestial.
Evolution.
Dude, congrats.
I'm proud of you, man.
I got GM1.
All right, good luck, boys.
Another epic victory.
Yay.
Yippee!
I'm rushing the stream.
It's because I'm on my third stream.
All right.
Yeah!
Oh my gosh, God, I'm gonna be a damn one!
Oh my gosh!
They're gonna be so proud of me!
Who's that?
They are gonna be proud of me!
Boom!
Bum, bum, bum.
Little Doki gonna be GM1.
Um, I'm sorry, but I'm actually not Doki Bird.
Um, you got mistaken.
Now, not Doki Bird is gonna hang out and flex her new emote
that she got for the first time.
Where are my people?
Oh my god.
Wow.
Oh.
Hey guys.
Hello beautiful women.
Would you like me to...
Happy New Year.
How many plans?
Eternity.
It's Eternity.
But I also play on and off a lot.
no it's okay guys we have let's go triple support gambit
i'm gonna eagle gambit
i'm pulling still i don't remember i got eternity with moxie
and then like yo we got mine we had a win streak and then i
stopped on my win i stopped i was like i end stream when we
lose a game my and then i got eternity and then i lost game
and then i stopped oh you like mic and likes hell no those
suck oh no okay you're joking they're they're goaded i don't
know those are not good i don't know i can't do a math i
think guys remember what i peaked at i don't remember it's
been so long because i got top 500 in season one and then i
i stopped all right if you don't and i just play for fun
because that's Like, my name is on the leaderboard.
I don't care anymore.
No, those are good.
I made my mark.
Okay, now I'm going to test you again.
It was top 200.
I got top 200.
I ended top 200.
Yeah.
And I called it.
Wait, hold on, bro.
Hold on.
Do I even answer it?
No!
Can I...
Fucking hell, okay.
Yeah, I made my mark and then I just fuck around.
Because my voice is not my main content.
Dude, I recently...
I, like, took Jolly Ranchers.
I took all the red colors and mixed it in with Sprite.
That was, like, the most diabetes bomb possible, but it
tasted so good.
Yeah, no, I'm washed.
30 seconds before you attack.
I already won my voice.
You guys gotta help me win my game.
At least I know I can trust you.
of every dps player in the fucking lobby i guess you know
someone else could tink with me i don't care who it's
someone yeah i'm Vlad you streamer i don't i don't play dps
like that or i mean i don't play tink like that it's my game
but okay but it's but it's like i play off stream more so
when i'm like when i'm lucky all right come on guys we're
gonna portal and our spider-man's gonna
here really okay all right oh my and then he fucking drops
down oh my god just you know okay at least he came back up
but still i was not expecting oh and then he drops down all
right let's hope he goes backwards oh man on them.
That was a fucking weird-ass TP, I will say.
Yeah, like that.
He has a Lord icon.
I did not really.
How the fuck did he farm that?
Played Hytale.
I mean, you played that, or no?
Okay, I don't think we should be on Penny.
I will say that.
Buddy, bro, you're selling my game.
Oh, no, no.
He's not the all-kid.
He's not...
He's not the only one selling.
I can tell.
Don't worry.
Bro, I...
You're flying and like...
Are you dying off cooldown?
It's fun when you die again.
How's that fun?
Alright, I'm gonna...
Alright.
Hey!
Again!
We need some matches?
Okay.
That is unfortunate.
Oh, it's fine.
Hey guys, there is...
I am just gonna...
Okay.
There is no way you're complaining about that.
All right, that spider-man's gonna fuck us up.
Okay, that spider-man's gonna fuck us up.
Okay.
All right.
I always...
It's tab.
I don't know.
He literally goes into that.
This is the only way he'll ever get healed.
Oh my god, I get his name.
He's the guy that drives by, so then just dies.
Bro, this is the only way he'll ever get healed.
Like, right here.
It's time.
This is literally the only way this guy will ever get
healed.
And even then, he's going to find a way to die.
All I'm saying is you have this.
Oh, that is unlucky for me.
Oh, my God.
I need...
Oh, hey, hey, it's fine.
Spider-Man, there's no way.
There is no way you're complaining about not getting healed.
I saw what happened.
I...
There is no way.
I nearly saw what happened.
Salvage the title on it.
Oh, hey, he fucked up.
He fucked up.
You're five.
Never probably seen a Ferrari in life.
He's opening a portal in the...
There we go.
I have to use that, but there we go.
All right, I'm going to predict where he is.
This is very hard.
Oh, my God.
Where is my Envis?
I can't go.
Oh, my God.
She went that way.
Oh, we see nine.
All right.
The current score is zero.
I'm lucky.
Yeah, like.
There is no way.
I even gave him a snowflake.
Why I'll cover...
Because it's my alt account.
I don't play on this account very often.
So I...
The last time I played on this account, Loki wasn't meta.
So I had no reason to play Loki on this account.
Oh, we're flowing now.
It's time.
Oh, it's time.
Oh, that's Animal Crossing.
Let's go.
I don't know why.
Like, my game's like nice volume, but randomly, like, it
seems like it's, like, really low.
Nice volume.
Yeah, main grip.
What's your E though?
I will say Celestial is like, all right.
GM is, but, like, not like.
No, but like, it does it on Arch Raiders, too.
I won't say pitch, though.
I just say, all right.
I don't know why.
It's like randomly, um, like I noticed it like a few days
ago.
I was like, hmm.
There are, I agree.
There are a lot of inflated players.
Blasting my ears.
And like, now I can barely hear.
You talk like you know about this game a lot.
We have to stop them from securing the mission area.
Secrets always come out.
Oh, console.
Okay, I get it.
Because console is different from PC.
No, I'm just saying it's different environment.
It's like how Overwatch PC is different from console.
That's all I'm saying.
Wait, this guy's only kill was my kill.
I forgot my kill, Cole.
I think he is the world record for...
I'm saying console is different from PC.
It's a different...
Yeah, but PC has all the pro players.
It's good for avoiding this guy off cooldown.
But we do have controller players on PC.
So it's a lot...
And then PC top pro players also are hog up 50% of the top
500.
I will say PC top players hog up the pro players have 50% of
the top 500 leaderboards.
With five of their alt accounts So like So they're facing So
like you barely face like Other That's why it's so hard to
find games in top 500 The reason why PC top 500 is low Is
because the pro players have like 50% of the leaderboards So
like you can't find the players in the top 500 lobby Because
they have longer queues Because they are 50% of the
leaderboards yeah that's why their cues are so fucking long
how do they play they wait like 10 plus minute cues
sometimes 30 minutes i've seen pro players wait like 30
minute cues for one game i think it would be higher if like
i think it would be higher if they have players to play
against literally the top 10 is like one person in our
fucking npc exactly so you can't really say that console has
higher top 500 to like be like oh skill wise because the
reason why pc is so low is because it's hogged but they they
had their queues are so fucking long.
So they can't really climb.
It's also a Gamba.
It is also a Gamba between Will your team have the pro
players in Eternity or not.
Penny?
That's interesting.
GM is so interesting.
It's like, oh yeah, it's like, I swear, I see the craziest
bands in this, you know,
of course I acknowledge, like, like, pro players complain
about queues all the time, but it's literally because, um,
the fact that, like, half the leaderboard is them, so it's
harder to matchmake because they're literally, they're,
they're literally playing against each other, like,
themselves.
Because they're like, we need to find another Eternity 200
player to balance up the match.
But then the Eternity 200 player is them.
They are the Eternity 200 player.
So now they have to find Eternity 200 players to balance it
out.
Yeah, like when the only person who's around your level
that's queuing at the same time is you, what the fuck do you
do?
Good luck, 30 minute queue.
Yeah, I'll wait until someone else pops up.
This is also why I like got bored of queuing high Elo.
It's because the wait time was so bad.
You guys remember D-Gen hours during D-Gen queues when we're
just like queuing on the higher Elo accounts?
And then we have to wait like 10 to 15 minutes.
And then I was just like I'm I'm bored.
I'm so bored.
I had to play and like In like the lower you know, so at
least I can have games Yeah, and then we get on Roblox and
then we had to we got on Roblox because we were just like We
were on Roblox in between queues.
Yeah
Bro, oh my god, okay I am very mispositioned by the way, but
it's fine.
I have TP.
I need reload though.
Okay, that's cool.
No, I just don't play as often anymore.
I don't, like, I'm still on my main account, but I don't
play as often.
Disappear!
also because i'm busy i'm also oh i forgot to do the
confirmation again i keep forgetting when i'm playing
fucking i'm like oh yeah i have to play i have to play loki
again i keep forgetting i'm pushing him back really okay i
was gonna say there's no way he does oh it's because we have
a rogue i'm lucky
are you fucking kidding me oh my god it's fine we didn't
need it so it's not like i wasted it i i like that up it's
okay it wasn't even a waste i literally was about to press q
and then it disappeared that's all right it's aura it's
always aura are you kidding me okay we gotta kill this guy
oh he made it too there is no way okay i'm gonna say that
was just aura at this point I'm not putting another colon
out.
I can't put another colon out.
That's the worst part.
Okay, I can now.
Where's her?
Invis.
Oh, that's unlucky.
I have this.
Oh, I'm an ace, though.
I'm ace.
Yeah, I know about that, bro.
I'll keep up to date with Ravus.
What did I miss?
Deadpool is really hard to play for support.
It's gonna take a lot.
It's gonna take people a long time to figure out how to
play.
Like, especially support.
I think support for him is the most difficult role.
Because, like, he's like a melee.
Like, you have to melee to, like, actually...
Please, I hope to grab you up.
This is the help.
Okay, like, it's fine.
Okay, now what is this?
Alright.
There's nothing I can do if he puts me up in the air.
Like,
like, I, guys.
I was in the air for, like, 10 seconds.
So, like, it would have been nice to get killed during that
time, I guess.
Oh my god.
Okay.
That double.
There you go.
Oh hey, the double support ult.
I'm fine with that.
There we go.
Just in case.
Hey guys!
Okay, there we go.
That's it.
Hey guys.
Hey guys, there we go.
Alright, nice.
Bullets here?
Yeah, but you have to be able to...
It's just...
You have to be able to balance between...
Someone that did the early access pre-built.
You have to be able to balance between the swords and...
Like, and the...
The swords and the bullets, too.
It's very confusing It's like you actually have to like It's
not it's like a fucking six star Fucking hero How?
Oh my god how Go moves Oh that is very unlucky I thought he
was gonna make it I thought he was gonna keep going right Oh
my god There we go At least I'm right here That's why it
doesn't matter
I'm getting harassed please send help I might go I might as
well go rocket because then at least like he'll start
harassing the invas instead of me and I'm fine with that
it's me or you and I choose me she oh my god okay I will say
she almost fucked over our team but she basically almost
alts it our entire team with the strange all that was crazy
to see is she actually oh my god that's crazy to see
oh that's unlucky i thought she was gonna so i'm waiting for
her Like she actually almost killed our entire team with
that look
Hey, she's all thing first keep me alive you hear that he's
gonna all first guys
Just in case there you go.
I fucking knew it I had a feeling he was gonna do that shit.
There is no way you're going outside.
Okay
Okay.
I'm fine with that.
I am not fine with that.
Jesus, already again?
There's nothing.
I didn't have shift.
Oh, pot.
Okay, I will say.
Our rogue?
I will, okay, no, actually, our mag.
Might be our mag, actually.
It's either a mag or a rogue.
Yeah.
That's fine.
Oh, we rock it.
I'm not dealing with, I'm not dealing with the Spider-Man.
I'm gonna let my, I'm gonna let my invis handle the
Spider-Man.
Oh, we're going triple support.
I mean, that also works.
You know what?
That also works.
Fuck it.
Let's go.
Now, our tanks are doo-doo.
That's fine.
It's fine.
The thing is, that's their mains.
I'm just vibing.
The Elo terrorist is here to vibe.
Like, fuck it, we ball.
Fuck it.
What?
Happens, happens.
See ya.
I'm on an altar cat.
I'm still playing my best.
Well, technically.
I mean, I had a yellow brick road, okay?
I did have a yellow brick road.
The cat rage bait me.
I'm immune.
I'm not dokey, babe.
Cat rage bait me.
It's okay, we're taking care of each other.
Alright.
Oh my god, that guy is so low.
Oh my god, it's because he sucked him up.
I was like, what the fuck?
I need to keep this for like...
Oh, he was so low.
I'll give him here.
I need to keep a lead for the spot, man.
Whenever he decides to show up.
Oh, wait, is that a...
Oh, he stopped.
All right.
What the fuck?
The one time.
Okay, then I don't have to keep my leaves.
I leave.
Jesus.
Oh, my God.
I got stuck.
Oh, fuck.
That was on me.
I got stuck.
Oh, my God.
And look, it's okay.
We have our fourth healer.
The Groot!
Yes!
Our four-peeler!
What can they do?
We technically are quad support!
Goar, stop!
You know what?
Fuck this.
Let's go.
Yeah!
Let's go!
Damage boosts everything!
The secret fourth healer.
The secret weapon.
What can they do about that?
One.
I might be dead.
But we still have another.
He will heal for me.
Oh,
that's unlucky.
Oh, that's fine.
There you go.
If all else fails, go triple support.
That's like the key.
All right.
As always, if all else fails, we still have triple support.
And our fourth secret healer.
All right, I'm not.
Oh my god, our rogue.
What the fuck did he fucking...
Oh my god, that was scared.
I'm trying to like make sure I don't waste much.
All right, well, I hope people are alive.
Oh, fuck wait, they're not.
What do we do?
Our only DPS is me and Rogue.
Go Rogue, go!
Oh my god, I'm so sad.
Wait, wait, wait, keep me up, keep me up, keep me up!
No!
Oh, I couldn't do anything.
I literally needed one more H, one more.
Oh my god, bro, I saved your life!
I saved my Invis life!
Where was my plus one?
It's okay, our secret fourth healer.
Our secret fourth healer is coming in clutch.
Go, go, go!
Go, go!
Oh my gosh, she disappeared.
You're not disappearing from me.
Oh my god.
That's okay, me and the Star Lord, we chillin'.
We have four healers in the backlight.
Oh my god, but we also have...
There we go.
What the fuck?
Like, look at that!
We did it.
What the fuck?
Technically, four support.
The tree.
The tree can heal this.
I told you.
Quad support.
Win and doubt.
Exactly.
Just out heal all the damage, forehead.
Yeah.
40k.
tournament.
I'm in the 200k tournament.
Yeah,
just need it.
We don't need no mag.
We need a fourth healer.
Oh, it's at 12 p.m.
PSD, guys.
It's going to be on YouTube.
true we only need no no we don't not Luna fist we just need
it we need a fifth healer who also gives us heals we
will do that quickly or how long till till I haven't found
my people yet I'm a little sad like where are my people
where are my dancers I have to oh
Papa.
Papa, I'm here.
No!
What of you?
Father, I have returned.
No!
They took my papa away from me.
And I played them bit.
I'll go.
Never get Gambit.
It's not fair.
You know what's crazy?
Offstream?
Offstream, I had both games.
They didn't ban Gambit.
It's not fair.
How come they didn't ban Gambit when I get to play Gambit?
I just won one Gambit game.
I'm about to show you guys what the rocket's for.
Oh, that is in this tab.
He's not healing.
He is not healing.
I'm solo healing this.
Actually, I'm taking the cough drop.
I'm risking it.
I'm risking it for the biscuit.
Alright.
I don't trust not Doki Bird because they don't know.
if I'm Doki Brood or not.
Wee.
Uh, tying all over on Rocket means he's not going to be
healing.
He's going to be shooting his gun.
The battle starts in five, four, three, two, one.
There is a limit to cough drops.
Well, you're not supposed to, we're not supposed Alright.
Jesus Christ.
He almost died.
Oh my god.
I stay here because there is a...
What the fuck?
Okay, I'm a little worried, right?
There you go.
Oh my god, this fucking Spider-Man is very annoying, though.
I will have to sit.
Get him out of here!
Jesus Christ!
Okay, this Spider-Man should not be that annoying.
But...
Like, the fact that our rocket is...
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I am a lot.
Okay, I'm gonna... you go first.
There you go.
Oh, that was... that's an early born again.
All right.
We still have all, right?
We still...
Guys, um, I don't like that you guys are all...
Oh yeah.
I could have kept it, but like...
I was not risking it.
I did not believe in my team.
Not in this elo.
Oh, they have three supports.
Yeah, no, we're fucked.
We don't have a support up.
What's the reason for it?
The reason is that there's one hour left of the rank.
I fucking knew it.
I was like...
Oh!
I didn't.
I was like, we don't have supportals, so like, good luck to
us, I guess.
Oh, there's the other supportals.
Bye.
I didn't have my shield, unfortunately.
I was, like, spamming that shit.
Yeah, I'm gatekeeping the...
Not last...
The gatekeeping the...
The people were trying to get to Celestia.
If I had a Celestia account, I would gatekeep eternity, too.
But unfortunately, I do not.
I know.
It really is very unfortunate that I can't...
potential you know I wish I could I would love to Elo
terrorize to my full potential okay
like we yeah I was gonna say we gotta get this guy oh my god
oh that's unlucky I didn't see it oh he is oh my god it's
red Ferrari it's his this God, I think if Tyler Lover was on
DPS and shut down the Spider-Man easily.
I would love to.
There you go.
Oh my god, you guys were so low.
I was, did not trust you.
I have to use that.
I hate that I have to use that.
Because now we don't have a support up.
But I think we would have lost if I did not.
They were like critical.
There you go.
I pushed them.
What?
It's alright.
Oh, it is not okay.
Oh, that is- we are not okay now.
Now we're not okay.
Oh, we are absolutely not okay now.
I've got them!
Oh, no more shield.
shields.
Let's hope that doesn't fuck me over.
I think it's because we also do not have, unfortunately, do
not.
Okay.
He missed.
Man.
Only shit.
Surely he doesn't hit me with that.
Yeah.
Oh my God, throwing him out of here.
I am Asgard's might Okay, let's...
Is he Asgard mighting?
Is he...
Is he doing it, though?
That's fine.
He has Asgard mighted.
Feeling fantastic.
Safe.
Oh, well.
That's fine.
That's no longer fine.
Thanks for the boost.
Feel the pull.
Oh, well.
Are you willing to help?
Oh.
The Spider-Man has all, I'll repeat.
The Spider-Man has all.
Oh, I put the shield.
I put the shield.
I did my job.
Oh my god.
I'm just going to use this on myself.
Oh, he is so dead.
Oh, my God.
I had that so unlucky.
All right.
A fucking curse.
Jesus Christ.
Please, he's so close.
Lord, you have to touch.
You have to touch.
No!
Where is it?
It's okay.
Watch this.
who c9
that is very unfortunate that that truly was very
unfortunate
That truly was Very unfortunate that that happened but truly
what?
misfortune The worst part is that I got rid of my okay, we
can push this up now Okay, we should kill this guy right
there we go What the fuck
Okay.
The Spider-Man doesn't know I'm here.
He doesn't know.
I fucking search.
Oh my god.
He doesn't know I'm right here.
I'm in my little puppy hug.
Okay, this is bad.
Oh, there we go.
Go it!
Nice.
Okay, now I go.
well.
Okay, this is when you cannot.
There we go.
Okay, I have, I don't have push.
Let's go.
The current score is zero.
The power of the DPS rock.
Time to switch things up, including which side.
Let's go.
I can't believe we see none that.
I was like, That was not the thing you're supposed to watch,
by the way.
That...
I said watch this, but the C9 was not it.
Swear to God, it was not the C9.
But it was fun.
But Tokyo was pretty funny.
It was, though.
I will admit.
It was pretty funny.
Wee.
I think my favorite part about the little accessories is
like Jeff Bunny and Deadpool's ash.
They know what they're doing.
Oh my god, gay.
I'm okay.
I don't know about it.
He's okay too, I guess.
Oh my god, I can't believe.
I mistimed that.
I snapped too far.
That was not intentional.
Alright.
That's fine.
I still care.
Or is I thorough care?
I'm okay, but there's our Thor.
Oh, our Thor is okay.
I need my shield, though.
But I already almost have.
Oh, what the fuck?
That's crazy.
Okay.
Hey, guys.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
Not for our group, though.
Our group.
Oh, our group's back.
That's fine.
Our group is back, though.
Oh, not our star lord, though.
Okay, I could do an aggressive out here.
I believe.
Do you believe?
I believe oh get her get her get her get her see I told you
I believe I built that all so fast
there we go yeah I don't know maybe we did not need that oh
let's go in Thor come over here let's set up the old combo
all right I'll tell you one okay I'll tell you when to go on
there's the spot scooter man all right you ready three two
one let's go go go go Are fucking, he's dead.
Guys, what about the scooter man, though?
What about the scooter?
Guys!
Guys, there's still a scooter man, though!
There you go.
Ha-ha!
I got the scooter, man.
There you go.
The drop team.
We did it.
We got him.
I said, what about it?
But little do they know?
I'm meant for them.
Oh, this guy is low, low.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
Bro, Invis is so fucking broken.
Oh, little did the Spider-Man knows?
Little does he know our Star Lord was the one that's on
point.
That's right.
A DPS was on point.
You can't bully us.
Oh, wait, but we gotta help this guy, though.
I don't feel safe right now.
Oh, yeah, that's why I do not feel safe right now.
Be back up, please.
I do not think you're safe.
Nah, I fucking knew it.
I fucking knew I didn't feel safe here.
Oh, my God.
Oh, that's unfortunate.
Okay, I was trying to find my shield.
I realized my shield was...
Oh, my God.
He didn't even know where I was!
He found me on the last second!
Oh my god.
This guy didn't even know.
He literally didn't see me until the last second, too.
He was like, 360.
Where is she?
We're going to press alt and I'm going to press alt.
We'll go here.
Oh.
Get over here.
That's right.
Go on.
Oh.
That was a little embarrassing from there, Phoenix.
their phoenix did not realize oh there you go that was silly
though what they oh oh god where is oh i was gonna say
where's my door i swear to god oh again bro how the fast is
he building is she
we are trying so hard to keep you up right now, Thor.
I swear to...
Okay, I don't have to ult, though.
At least.
Okay, I better not have to waste my ult here because that's
just two people.
Like, please kill this one guy.
There you go.
I was gonna say I was not wasting my ult.
Okay, I swear to God.
He fucking took his...
up forward?
Oh my god!
Who does that?
Oh, we got put.
He took his up forward.
Oh my god.
That's crazy.
Bro, he didn't even know I was there.
I didn't even know he was there because he was on high
ground.
Yeah.
I couldn't see him because he was like blocked by the
blocked by the about the height thing.
The other straight to me, I was like, okay, this all should
be fine.
This guy out of here.
Fucking give me pictures of Spider-Man right now.
God, who's a fucking menace?
God damn menace to society!
You need to be able to rock it in the house, though.
Yay!
Oh my god, he has more kills than our fucking Phoenix.
That is sad.
Bro, I'm glad Uncle Ben is dead.
He deserves it.
That's right.
That's how much...
Jesus, 20 final blows as rocket.
That's insane.
Whoa!
You should be glad, too.
Because without Uncle Ben dying, we won't have Spider-Man.
Silly?
He gave me someone to hate.
Thank you, Uncle Ben.
With your death, I have a true hate.
Like, I can finally hate freely.
Silly?
They will never have Spider-Man.
Yeah.
It wouldn't have 200 million Spider-Man skins without Uncle
Ben.
Red Ferrari Bro that fucking guy Is bad at video games Very
fond that guy He literally lost a 1v1 With a rocket Like
seven times That's up Bro I He fucking lost a 1v1 with me
I feel like Interseason is just people playing Playing like
Playing like Spoodle Man.
Bro, he was not talking.
In our game, bro.
That guy was so shit.
That he got yelled at by our team.
Then he never talked.
Because he's a fucking pussy.
Um, but I don't.
But I don't.
But I'm 30 more minutes.
Oh, I did not.
avoid Red Ferrari, by the way, so I hope Titan Law avoided
him.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
30 more minutes of gatekeep.
Oh, I should do one game of the Deadpool.
Well, I won't be playing Deadpool, but I should do one game
just to see what it's like.
Maybe I can play Gambit now.
Yo, look at that.
I went final, 20 final hits last game, and now they want me
to chill.
we have three tank players they just don't know I know well
I'll be honest I have my tracker open from when I was
playing my main we have three people for 80% winner in this
game so 30 wraps why the fuck use a tracker you fucking nerd
no you're a fucking nerd why do you have a fucking tracker
not at all how's that how's that being a nerd talk to me I
want to know because you're playing a game Where you you
already have the bet you how much of a pussy do you have to
be to use a track of the band stuff?
Wow Yes, yes, ladies You know, there's a tracker pedal game
soon.
Yeah, but I'm not a bitch.
You know, I don't use it.
We're all Dude, you're too scared
Yeah, I don't know what I'm gonna say Ladies, ladies.
You're the piggy.
Poinkoinko.
Whoa.
And
we track our kisses instead.
Round one.
Back to back to Invis.
Oh, that one's good.
I like that.
I like that one.
Oh, hell no.
I'm deep guessing.
No, no.
I actually don't fuck it.
Do it.
Let's do it.
Yo, I'm playing Penny F1.
Oh, okay.
Well, I don't like on this.
I'm at least a little bit tolerable with what I do.
Got a room, Lenny.
Enemies to lovers right here.
I feel like every time I try to play that, I like fall
asleep.
I like how they're like, we have three people who are 80%
win-right, and they don't give that one of the 80% win-right
DPS.
Oh, yeah.
Wait, wait, wait.
So, you rather play Rocket DPS with the DPS?
Luna.
I love Spock having a healer.
Nope.
All you need to do is capture the mission area.
More skillful to do on Rocket.
Oh.
What a fish.
They also got a penny though, so.
Watch.
All right, who's doing getting rid of the hot ground?
Ladies, ladies.
Shut up.
Positioning.
Behind them.
We got another one.
But I need this for myself.
Fuck that.
They can't walk back.
If they walk back, they're fucked.
Okay, please kill this guy though.
Oh my god.
We need more kills.
The fact that we did not.
We already have an old.
In what world do they already have an old?
I love it.
Oh
What we have a hallelujah OT from strange.
Oh Okay, I got my old too.
Don't worry man Oh my god Hey, I got through that kill Oh
Okay, like there's nothing.
I'm not popping up for this.
We died.
We had too many devs there was no way i was popping out for
that ladies ladies what is going on
my solar is one in three this is not my solar is a piggy
what's going on yeah you might need tracking for that guy
all right at least a negative one there you he shows peaks
what's my peak i know i know your peak is same as mine same
as mine well i don't know what's the number Okay, like I
can't do anything.
Oh, that's a...
Hey, Twine, don't worry, though.
Don't worry.
I'm right now top 200 of my man.
Yo, that's on big numbers.
Guys, I wanna up, but I can't because we keep staggering.
Why am I still taking on Penny Parker?
Oh.
Okay, I'm literally doing my job holding right click, but
yes, he's dying.
Like, I can't up.
Let me up.
Backs.
What is going on?
I know Vex and they're cheating overwatch I think I know one
too I can't wait I knew one on overwatch and it was Vex was
that guy's also cheating I just wanna up how can I up and
like fuck this this is the only time I cannot apparently
like this is the only time I blocked that i got you i got
you all right
there we go look at i i got you all at least i i get to all
i am here i am here
oh my god don't worry oh my god okay there's a skill with
phoenix on the left all right be nice.
All he has to do is hold last question.
There we go.
I like the only person.
The only person that should be playing DPS is not playing
DPS.
We did not kill the Punisher.
Oh my god.
We all just pushed forward and then forgot that there was
one more person on the team.
That's actually crazy.
We all just stared at the Punisher on the fucking point.
Donna.
I'm getting terrorized.
The ELO terrorizer has become fucking terrorized right now.
TV right now.
Oh my god,
is my team okay.
That's a question that I'll keep asking.
Don't worry.
You shall live forever.
Watch.
Never mind.
I don't want to do it.
I'm not doing it.
I was like, watch.
Oh, no, I'm not doing that.
There we go.
We lived, though.
don't worry i don't want to do oh where's our bucky oh that
that was our bucky
really okay
i'm scared oh rocky there is
no way you're scared of this guy I was gonna say there's no
way myself a reservoir right next to me hold on There you
are I was gonna see how you all scared What the fuck I'm so
fine I rock it dead.
Oh, I don't worry.
Oh, I don't worry
It's okay
We can live just a little longer.
We can do this.
That's right.
Okay, but like, I need you to live, though.
There we go.
We lived on.
Get out of here.
Get out of my point.
Investive right there.
Investive.
The most fucking stupid Help you up, Piggy.
Oh my god.
There's that word.
There's one more.
Oh, baby, you're so weird.
Oh my, that's on him, bro.
That was, that's on him.
All right.
Oh my god, 60 seconds left.
seconds left really okay
like you guys are taking way too much damage from my liking
I'm doing that wait wait wait for us I'm waiting I'm the the
lion waits for its prey I got this they won't know yo get
that suit trying to ego us bro I know
Jesus Are you all ready?
Oh my god That's unfortunate Don't worry That's very
unfortunate You are the only healer I got another one Oh my
god I hope my team Alright it's fine it's fine it's fine
It's fine.
I saved my ult, guys.
I saved my ult for
Can't do shit.
You can't do anything.
Look at that Okay.
Hello?
Did you guys just ignore the Phoenix?
No, where's my diver?
I'm literally behind me okay look i got burned i could not
even process what just happened to me i i couldn't even
process i just exploded i got kablooey and then it was over
time to switch things up including which side i don't think
there was any saving me there you'll need a top-notch team
to win this one i'm not the type who fades quietly but that
was not an invis diff guys that invis was like she like I
was bleeding out and then she like she like just and then
she like got a toothpick and poked me in the toe and I died
Just as I lost all my blood.
Why were you so alpha?
Oh my god because the phoenix the phoenix was the one that
did everything
I was really bleeding at the phoenix like got like 20 dives
into me and it's like at two phoenix and then he was like
And then like and then the infants Got a toothpick.
Rock it.
My dying breath.
Oh, my God.
And she stabbed me with a toothpick.
And then I died.
That still sounds like it.
It just...
I'm still...
I'm like crossing my feet right now.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
I got some animals in here.
I've tuned this out.
Boys got boys being boys.
This is called Welcome to...
rank we're 30 with 20 minutes left I mean 10 minutes left
for range I'm holding right side I think I can handle the
shit by myself you guys just hold on No, he's fine.
I'm dead.
No, he's fine.
He's healthy.
I'm glad you got a better team, apparently.
Don't worry.
Whoa.
My little shield is still there.
Still have my shield.
I was left side looking.
Last side looking pretty well.
Holding right.
Oh, shotgun penisher up top.
Are they fine over there?
I'm coming.
Oh my god, I hope everyone is okay.
How is my...
Okay, I noticed my...
Oh, just when I was about to...
The damage potential on this character.
They have no idea.
They don't know about the aura.
Oh my...
Okay, I gotta give myself shield real quick.
Oh, that is not good.
Oh, he actually just went out of me.
Bro, he's throwing.
Oh, yeah, I'm definitely better.
Oh, I just got balls from CK.
I did.
We're fine.
Oh, my God.
I don't know what happened.
Oh, y'all are so sexy.
Oh, my God.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you, man.
You're seeing a...
Oh, my.
Look, let's go.
Better than Eric Armin.
So let's go.
Oh, what about Crimson?
Hmm.
I gotta think about that.
So healthy right now?
No, you got me playing with my hairs right now.
Oh yeah.
Oh my god.
Okay, at least we have Rocket up, but they do have Phoenix
up though, so like I'm a little concerned.
Oh, it's okay.
So he still has, he still has second life.
Oh my god.
Go, go get him.
Okay, wait a minute.
Is he okay?
He's not okay.
Wait, I still have up.
That's fine.
Oh, fuck no!
Okay, it's okay, it's okay.
It's okay, I got the boop.
I got the boop.
Alright, well, I don't have all of that, though.
Oh my god, I think I booped him into the into the spotty
mines.
Wait, that's crazy.
I actually moved him into the slaty, man.
It might be.
Dude, it has to be, bro.
I'm, like, too scared to get near him now.
Armed and dangerous!
Okay, but who is the arm and dangerous?
Okay, that's a bit.
Oh, yeah, I won.
Oh, my.
Easy.
Okay, don't let him get me, though.
Don't let him get...
Don't let the shotgun Punisher, man, get me!
oh my god i don't know how i live holy i'm i'm doing the
heels of the century right now i got all the get i got all
the get i'm actually healing for i'm healing for the century
this is like generational heal don't worry everyone keep
going keep going oh my god he just oh my god
I just have them.
Oh my, they're so healthy.
They are so healthy.
Actual.
You're making me so...
You're making me quiver.
Yeah, they heal so hard.
The grandkids are feeling the excess residue healing from
me.
I am providing the free health care for my team.
There's Invisdiff right there.
Jesus fucking Invisdiff right there.
You guys can't see this.
Okay, she had not a lot of heals.
That's all you have to know.
We have enough for one more.
That's all.
I told you.
I told you guys.
That is like generational healing.
We got to nerf her.
The crazy part is that she's not really that nerfed.
I think Gambit is...
Invis are still going to be meta.
I mean, Gambit Invis, Loki.
Is there actually?
Oh my god, eight minutes left.
Eight minutes left of terrorism.
Red Ferrari added?
Oh my God.
Wait.
The red Ferrari guy added me.
That's crazy.
That's insane.
Bro.
That's crazy.
Well, this guy is actually on an alt account, too, by the
way.
You guys don't see it, but, um, it's actually, it's an alt
account because it's level 37.
Ha!
My alt account is lower level and same rank as yours.
Yeah.
I win.
Bro, he had, like, he had a snowflake, too, when he was
coming.
playing but here's oh my god 15 thank you for the five gift
that sucks thank you thank you saw i didn't see it earlier
but thank you it was 24 minutes ago but thank you so much uh
gomez after the rank thing new season comes out we play one
game of the new season i don't know if he's listening if he
doesn't respond in the next 10 seconds i type it out why is
so much cake oh okay he is listening we play one game of the
new season on our mains i want to i want to i want to see
the deadpools oh it doesn't go live until 7 a.m usually goes
live right away Wait, what?
It's going to be like a turbo cancer, though.
That's okay.
There's no...
Wait, really?
Usually they do it right away.
Ah.
New down-down time.
In a pass, it wasn't like that, so I didn't...
I don't know.
I didn't know that.
They give us downtime now?
What the fuck do we do during downtime?
Where the fuck?
Did they give?
Did they?
I never...
You guys know, you guys can tell I've never played a new
season.
Oh,
shit.
Now we have a rocket player.
You are not playing DPS.
You are not...
You are not playing support.
Get the fuck off.
I know.
That's why I'm on Luna to do DPS.
We're never playing with Super Gov. miss again after this
after this game
where but we have oh wait we're triple support never mind
you're fine i don't think we have a dps player i don't think
we have a dp you're right i just remembered we could play
triple support.
I forgot.
And he was never seen.
I think the other guy I think this guy is a support player.
I swear to God, if this guy plays support, you gotta swap
off.
Alright, because he played support last time I've seen this
guy.
Oh, no, never mind.
We're fine.
Alright, triple support time.
Life energy is a powerful weapon against evil.
What do you say?
Finish.
I did not get bad at him.
That is fake news.
That is not...
That is not fake.
That is fake news.
I am just blackmailing him.
That's different.
Being mad and blackmailing someone is two different things.
It's such an emotional time.
I like it.
Wait, why?
30 seconds before you attack.
I didn't say whether or not it's good or bad.
I didn't say whether or not it's worse.
I'm just saying there are two different things.
I never implied it was better.
I'm just saying there is...
It's blackmail.
Not mad.
The battle starts in 5, 4, 3, 2,
bro he killed her fucking oh shit hey we lost like
okay he should win this okay that's embarrassing that is
embarrassing you're losing this fight that is embarrassing
you're okay there we go
i was gonna say you are losing the 1v1 right now with like
20 leaves on you i literally gave it so many leaves he has a
drone i'm just not a 1v1 yes it is i see one he's
all i'm seeing is that there we go get this guy out of here
all right oh my god i'm actually slouching my chair i am not
fucking paying this game i i'm literally like fully
slouching my chair being like you know like the the south
park um the one who has no life that's that was the position
i was playing in right there i was literally like slouching
fully and it's still like killing people i think that's
great you know Let's go.
Let's let you go.
There we go.
That's embarrassing.
I'm alive.
There we go.
I'm winning your 1v1 for you.
I'm literally winning your 1v1s.
What's your excuse?
You were running away.
Wait, I was winning that 1v1.
I got him.
Where is he?
Oh, wait, that's our hell up.
That's the enemy alone.
Here we go.
There we go.
They were both right!
Like, you just don't help far.
Are you fucking kidding?
Bro, he's dead.
so dead he
is so dead oh my god he got solo up dude that's crazy bro
what is this Elo like I should not be like really running
down things like how I'm playing right now like that's crazy
these guys these guys are not desperate enough for Eela.
He wants the grid up right there.
He's definitely looking for it.
These guys are not, do not want the, uh, these guys do not
want Eela as badly as I thought they do.
Okay, guys!
That's okay, I have my own.
So, I did the wrong DPS healer.
Yeah.
Oh, I'm coming over here.
Don't worry!
Speed!
There we go.
I made it just in time.
See, look, my stats aren't bad at all.
I'm basically DPSing.
I did more DPS than you.
team to win this one life energy is a my ultron lip time to
pull out the mask
i gotta i gotta i gotta afford 4k what is his excuse six
thank you for the super thank you for the twitch prime thank
you thank you
sorry i got confused which platform i'm on
pop i'm fucking killing it that you need a bigger gun this
leg
oh this is my rank up bro this was your this bro sorry bro
it's no longer your rank up Welcome to the Edo Terrorism
Day.
Should not queue on your main on the last hour.
Oh, it's a lesson for all of you.
I saw on him.
That he thought he was going to climb.
Oh, I hear the wolf.
Where did he go?
Oh my god, I don't know.
like magic oh my god he actually left he was like I'm not
winning this game oh my god it's bro this guy was like I am
not winning this game and he actually left because it's
literally the last game of the season and he was like this
is a he literally he has an excuse to leave that's actually
crazy he actually has an excuse to leave because there was
no way he's winning it anyway
yeah like they're so quiet oh my god they're actually
chasing him that's crazy he's so dead okay now it's equal
all right oh my god they're camping him they're trying to
camp him right now that's crazy oh my god the wolf is the
wolf is Oh, the wolf is coming over to kill him.
That's insane.
Oh, my God.
Is Z going to live?
That's crazy.
I'm going to watch this 1v1.
They're five.
There you go.
You were supposed to 1v1 someone else?
Hello?
Wrong person.
You're lucky I let you live.
You're so lucky.
You're so lucky I let you live.
I gave you a pass.
Oh yeah, you're gonna...
Yeah, you're gonna run now?
Wrong person.
There we go.
Everything's fine.
I'm not even focused right now.
Oh,
what the fuck is this?
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Oh my god, you're fucking crazy.
Where did he born again?
Oh shit, he has...
He's on the back.
He's fucking solo up to you.
That's crazy.
Bro, we had an insane record to them.
To be fair, this GM.
No, this Wolf has, oh, I'm fucking not sitting close to that
guy.
He doesn't care.
Oh my god.
There's like a 2v1 right now.
It's not even a 1v1.
He's like literally fighting for his life right now.
Bro, he has to stop.
You gotta stop this.
Are they still back there trying to kill him?
They are.
They're literally just camping him over and over again.
He's dead again.
No, the crew is kicked.
Yeah.
that's like insane 19 kills final blows 19 final blows
that's insane
oh baby a triple
it's it's gone my whole purpose is gone what a game to end
on guys what a fucking crazy game to end on that's that's so
funny that the guy left because he was like we're not
winning the guy actually left because he was like he was
like it's over
yeah yeah we have what it was our record one two three four
seven eight nine oh my god nine two that's pretty good nine
two that was a good-ass record one of one of them was a
thrower i don't know how i lost this oh this one um this one
oh wait two of them we had a thrower right yeah two of them
we had throwers so like like they were just uncarryable at
that point.
I don't even think they were throwing.
They were like playing in their elo.
But yeah, we did it.
We gate kept someone.
Oh my god.
This guy.
This guy was, was literally two points away from getting
Celestial.
Oh my god.
Oh, it is his career highest.
Okay, it's not, it's this season high.
He would have got, oh my god, we did it.
Yippee.
Yay, I gate kept him Let's go He literally needed Two
points, gate has been kept Nothing personal, kid Nothing
personal You gotta play this season earlier Another, another
successful day at work Yay
but i'm had a fun time to them thank you all for keeping me
company guys my third stream of the day um for those who are
new here my name is jokie bray i usually stream on youtube i
will be streaming the marvel rivals uh super 200k tournament
on youtube so i will be not twitch but on youtube uh so
check me out there it'll be at 12 p.m pst um i'll make a
waiting room later um and if you like my stream please
follow me on youtube that is my main platform you want to
know what